ice cream
this yeah
we can start now we're live streaming uh
good afternoon
and welcome to this strata joint
executive committee virtual meeting
today
25th of january 2021 i'm your chair
councillor paul arnott like to welcome
anyone watching meeting by live
streaming as well
everybody here today is taking part
remotely as well as being
live streamed on youtube and the
meetings being recorded too so obviously
please bear in mind throughout
and be mindful of your language uh
also i believe we're all under our
relevant codes of conduct throughout the
meeting
in the incredibly likely event anybody
wishes to disrupt it
we will reserve the right to disconnect
by any means
the meeting is dependent upon internet
connection the power supply
and if we lose those we'll try and come
back within 15 minutes if not we'll have
to
uh we'll have to reconvene at a later
date
and those details will be published on
our websites
please make sure all microphones are
muted when you're not speaking to avoid
any background noise levels keep points
short do not repeat points that have
already been made
and do not interrupt if you wish to
comment please raise your electronic
hand and
wait to be called um we'll now
start the meeting by doing a very short
roll call of the committee members
here present and if you can unmute your
microphones and when you hear your name
please confirm by saying you are
present thank you who would like to do
the rules
i'll do the role call councillor arnott
president councillor dewhurst
present councillor pearson president
sorry chair um sarah i i think you've
got your microphone very close to your
mouth
there's a there's a very strong sound
loud
sound of of sort of breathing okay
i'm not sure if it's you but somebody
somebody has
we've got a heavy breather thankfully
there are a few obvious suspects but
unfortunately it's you in the frame
ceremony so well
okay thank you for pointing that out so
diplomatically counselor to do hurst
um right moving on to the agenda then
apologies
do we have any apologies for absence
please sarah
i have none thank you very much item two
is to approve the minutes of our last
meeting which was held on the 22nd of
september 2020. uh if anybody wishes to
comment on those
i think in these circumstances please
just shout out there are so few of us
rather than blue hands uh
no so those all look good so therefore
we can record those minutes as being
agreed
thank you uh we now move on to
declarations
of interest uh and everybody's reminded
of me to declare any disposable
uh pecuniary interests that relate to
business on the agenda which have not
already been included in the register of
interest
before any discussion takes place on the
item
unless the interest is sensitive you
must also disclose the nature of that
interest
in accordance with the code of conduct
you must then leave the room and must
not participate in any further
discussion of the item
council is requiring clarifications to
seek the advice of their monetary
officer prior
to the day of the meeting so it's a bit
late now uh
anybody like to declare a an interest of
any kind
so so i'm a member of devon county
council
thank you alex there for that uh ollie
anything for you
no no and i won't declare anything
either thank you very much
uh item four is questions from the
public
um sarah i don't believe we do have any
questions from the public is that
correct
we have none thank you very much indeed
for that
uh item five is to receive
questions from members of the councils
um is anybody here from any of the
councils who would like to ask any
questions here today please
i'm not aware we haven't been notified
any questions in advance of the meeting
and there's no one
um here to ask questions thank you very
much for that sarah okay
item six then we move straight on to the
i.t directors report please
and i think that is lawrence coming
forward with that so over to you
lawrence whitlock thank you
yeah uh good afternoon everybody
laurence whitlock i.t director
um rather than go through my usual uh
set of slides etcetera um we really just
wanted to ask whether there's any
questions about the report that was
um submitted along with the pack uh
obviously if anybody's got any questions
uh please um ask them
[Music]
anybody have any questions for lawrence
if not then we thank him for that report
and note it thank you very much indeed
yeah could i have a proposal in
secondary sorry
for that one please yes okay well may i
be arrogant i'll propose from the chair
if that's okay and it's over to alistair
or ollie to win the second prize
alistair thank you very much indeed
thank you okay
thank you thank you for that sarah okay
and we now
come to the finance director's report
and i'm trying to work out who from
strata is giving that so
please just step forward
i can't see anything chair it's uh dave
hodgson
oh dave there you are sorry my screen's
a bit strange in the red jumper over
there right thank you very much okay
dave over to you for the finance
director's report please
thank you chair uh just to say uh strata
were tasked with uh delivering savings
of around 720
000 this year uh as per last year we
gave back 500 000
at the start of the year
and um as part of the response to
to the uh financial difficulties caused
by the
kovid pandemic strata um found an
additional
320 000 and police say
that at the end of november we're
projecting
that we're on track to deliver those
savings and i'm happy to take any
questions
okay thank you dave very much uh any
questions from members outside of the
committee
first or if not
committee any members
any questions yes ollie please counselor
uh pearson i should say thank you very
much david just in terms of the
return of savings which is i'm sure to
all three councils in the current
circumstances very
um welcome uh i just wanted to go as i'm
new to this committee just wanted to
understand uh the
process by which um you've come to
agree or decide to return those
particular amounts to the council
okay dave you happy to take that one i
am so
so the proportions are still in line
with the original
agreement under under the original
contract
uh dating back to 2014
and that's that the savings
or refund is returned in accordance with
the percentages that have agreed
uh for the initial contributions so
roughly speaking
36 point
five percent for east devon 35.9
for exeter and 27 for for team bridge
so so that that stays the same each each
year
please perhaps just clarify my
question it wasn't uh relating directly
to the proportions which i'm aware of
it was um the obviously in the context
of the pandemic
there's been additional savings which
are welcome i'm just wondering how
would strata was kind of come to the
position of making those savings
deciding that where to save and
uh et cetera so
so uh back at um in
june uh the board had a had a meeting
the the management team had had gone
away and very similar to the
the savings that were uh set out for
exeter in the
uh emergency budget back in july it's uh
mainly things that could be delayed so
vacancies being held till the end of the
the financial year for example
there were some additional savings from
contracts uh but we haven't
uh similar to to exeter we haven't uh
put in place anything that's permanent
so
so there's no permanent reductions in
staff for example it's
it's temporary uh in nature
councillor pearson is that okay for you
that satisfies me thank you
okay thank you very much indeed alistair
are you
uh happy there okay as am i
may i have a proposal please for us to
uh accept that finance director's report
chair happy to propose and the second
time
i was thinking that one thank you is
this this
[Music]
that's uh in the minutes as well thank
you very much indeed
um we now move on to uh item
eight and i have to blurb here because
we're going to go into part
two part b or in committee depending
upon where you live in devon
and we've resolved uh we have to pass
this resolution
that under section 184 of the local
government act 1972
the press and public be excluded from
the meeting during consideration
of the following item on the grounds
that involve the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph three of part
one schedule 12 a of the act
and the items suggested for discussion
with the press and public excluded
is as i said the strata business plan
2021 and beyond
uh committee are we content and agreed
to go into part b
for that please yes i can see nods from
both councillors do you host pearson and
me
i go stain on that one chair you're
going to abstain
okay well maybe i will
no let's let's let's that gets through
thank you very much
uh in which case sarah you need to lead
us into the uh
wilderness yes i'll stop i'll stop live